you're listening to songs talking about
raping women when you're watching films
oh have you not I think I could show you
guys I think
I think what I think is
in it is how like you you use very
minute kind of um anomaly like
situations far out of Norm yeah to
justify very extreme beliefs I don't
think so I think I could say whatever I
wanted and you would never agree because
that's one thing I know you you seem to
avoid accountability at every level
okay for example you say if Paul says
say so for example your housing this
Alleyway thing you're talking about
right and if anyone says maybe you could
move somewhere else you could do it this
way I did you seem to always look for a
reason to not have control agency over
these situations